[Musique]
le chèque énergie est un dispositif du
ministère de la transition écologique et
solidaire avec cette aide l'état
accompagne les ménages à revenus
modestes dans le paiement de leurs
dépenses d'électricité
c'est le nouveau dispositif dead qui
remplace le tarif de première nécessité
[Musique]
le chèque énergie s'adresse aux
personnes disposant de revenus modestes
il est attribuée sous conditions de
ressources et selon la composition du
foyer
pour en bénéficier vous devez déclarer
vos revenus aux services fiscaux
vous recevrez automatiquement le chèque
énergie à votre domicile il va vous
permettre de payer des factures
d'électricité du logement ainsi que
certains travaux de rénovation
énergétique pour payer votre facture
d'électricité
vous devez envoyer votre chèque énergie
à edf en métropole vous devez
accompagner votre chèque d'une copie de
votre facture d'électricité
vous pouvez également demander que le
montant du chèque soit automatiquement
déduit de votre prochaine facture edf
directement en ligne sur le www.ch
qu'énergie point gouv.fr vous ne
recevrez plus le chèque énergie par voie
postale
les démarches se feront automatiquement
pour plus d'informations sur le chèque
énergie vous pouvez vous connecter sur
le www.ch qu'énergie point gouv.fr ou au
numéro vert le 0 805 204 800 5